normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Elon
musk's Media Matters lawsuit will have a
chilling effect musk has filed his
thermonuclear suit against Media Matters
for America at the same time the Texas
AG launched an investigation into the
nonprofit now this we saw yesterday of
course there's a bunch of updates today
it's slowly moving I think the the fact
that the AG is going for criminal
charges against these organizations is
particularly interesting but here's what
was interesting this morning and this is
something I don't see a lot of people
writing up just yet but it's something
that must be covered Google search Elon
Musk and click news and what do you get
well what's the biggest Story I mean
this is a massive lawsuit you've got a
massive boycott X is being slammed by
Major advertisers the tune of tens of
millions of dollars but you know that's
that story Falls to uh uh Second Stage
the top story right now is farri
conspiracy theorist accused 22-year-old
Jewish man of being a Neo-Nazi then Elon
Musk got involved aspiring lawyer sues
Elon Musk Jewish student sues Elon Musk
all of a sudden all of these different
Outlets a bunch of different Outlets
start running a story instead that Elon
Musk is being sued for uh this is the
crazy thing about this story let me let
me let me show you this CNN runs uh runs
this this is uh last night at 10:12 p.m.
it was it was it was updated that's
that's a couple hours after he launches
the story now news that this dude was
suing Elon Musk is from I believe mid
October or early October here's what
they write Ben Brody says his life was
going fine he had just finished College
stayed out of trouble and was prepping
for law school then seemingly out of
nowhere Elon Musk uses his considerable
social media clout to amplify an online
mob's misguided rant accusing the
22-year-old from California of being an
undercover agent in a Neo-Nazi group
that's completely false that's actually
very very false Elon Musk replied to
someone vaguely referencing a guy who
was in college and wanted to work for
the government and no one accused the
the the the individual of being an
undercover agent in a Neo-Nazi group
they accused these people all of them of
being undercover agents period in a fake
Nazi group now whatever what I can say
is Define coordinated I suppose when a
bunch of media Outlets all run this
story and it shoves down the big news
and covers it up it's kind of like uh
every time what was the thing that was
happening every time Hunter Biden you
know was was caught doing something
aliens were proven to exist yeah I mean
just this week they they an example of
this is like he launches the rocket the
the the spa Starship he gets up the
largest spacecraft in history makes the
separation successfully and gets into
space and I try to look up the news and
it's all like Elam mus fails with rocket
because it blows up or you know lies
yeah it's just it's just straight up
fult it's one of the most successful
moments in history so and they and and
all the headlines are his he failed
they're all lies this was uh the first
launch uh it wasn't the first launch uh
SpaceX launched something a year ago or
whatever yeah all the media reports
shocking failure mediate rocket explodes
SpaceX intentionally blew it up they
they were doing a launch to collect data
uh so SpaceX launches Starship they did
the exact same thing they launched it to
collect data because they have to build
a rocket do you do it well you have to
build prototypes try them see where they
fail collect the data and then the
safety measure is you blow up you blow
them up yep and the media reports that
he's a failure it's not working this is
crazy and then at the same time this
whole entire anti-semitic thing comes
out or they're covering his custody
battle with Grimes a lot right now paint
him as terrible moral person the last
time you had us here it was a Fabian
Martin story about sound of Freedom that
the financier of sound of Freedom was a
sex trafficker and it was a guy who is
totally exonerated later on but he was
all over the press and his face was
everywhere and they were trying to take
that film down it was also like one of a
100 thousand investors I believe wasn't
it yeah he was one of thousands
investors 50 bucks wow he gets accused
of an accessory to
kidnapping and it the and then it got
the judge was like I don't know how
you're an accessory to kidnapp him
because there's no even charge for
kidnapping but somebody went into the
theater screenshotted all the investor
names cuz that's the only place you can
get them then digitized them wow then
crosscheck them across all the local
criminal databases to find one guy who
had been accused of a kidnapping and
then the headline is finance year $50
investor of thousands of sound of
Freedom arrested for kidnapping children
MH I'm in London I have my angel shirt
on I'm at this TSA security in London I
don't know what what they call it there
and the one of the security guys comes
up and says oh I have tickets to your
movie and he's like are you the producer
and I was like oh no I I'm not the
producer I'm a distributor he's like oh
good because the producer apparently is
like a kidnapping
kids well now they're going they're
going after uh Tim Ballard with all
these stories which sound completely
insane but I got to tell you man but you
get like what What's Happening Here is
very common so what did you do
personally and what do you advise people
to do when the media run stuff like that
there was a a really wise um the one of
the executive producers on the one of
the films was coming up he's in his
90s very successful businessman and he
just called and said guys when the when
everybody's shooting at you get in the
Foxhole or else you'll get
shot well there you go so don't make
noise basically stay just stay calm and
keep I don't I I don't know though I
don't know though you look how the look
what the media does they they say uh the
best defense is a good offense when Elon
Musk goes after Media Matters and is
exposing what I believe expands the
government collusion narrative in the
censorship industrial complex we've got
the releases from the Republican party
we know about the releases from the
Twitter files now Elon Musk is going
after Media Matters and they're saying
they have data hard proof that Media
Matters fabricated the claims against
them to try and get advertisers to pull
out what does the media do immediately
launch a totally different story to
attack Elon Musk to drown it out y so
I'm I'm kind of wondering if perhaps in
in you know World War I style trench
combat you're getting shot at you get
down that's a good point but perhaps in
the world of PR and media what Elon Musk
needs to do is lay around another story
immediately now the issue of course is
will the Press even cover it or will
they let the Search terms be accurate
right and and and here's the thing I I
think it's probably Google look why are
people writing in this story I think
it's very weird that CNN chose to write
a month and a half old story and just
publish it right now with vague and
misleading language what do we call that
we call that Mal information it's it's
technically the truth but it's not
actually what's going on and then other
outlets pick it up because this is what
they do Google knows put this on top so
when it appears at the top of Google
when you search for Elon Musk I think
it's a big Tech play and I think big
Tech is colluding with the government
because we've already seen hard proof
they've been doing it or and or that the
advertisers are coordinating and they
all advertise on alphabet and on
whatever companies are posting this CNN
and all these people are getting that
same ad money that pulled out of Twitter
and they're they're working I don't know
if they're just bystanders in this or if
they're complicit I think it's difficult
for people as an individual to combat uh
the tech Giants and especially anyone
controlling a search engine if they if
if they want to I mean I'm I'm GNA
reference Taylor Swift I know you guys
were all waiting for it but when she
started dating tra Travis Kelce she went
to a New York Jets game before that when
you Google Taylor Swift Jet it talked
about all these articles from two years
before talking about her carbon
footprint and how bad it was and people
thought she has engineered this
relationship to get to this game so it
completely changes what shows up when
you Google these terms I mean the the
challenge here is that Elon Musk is now
up against the people who want CNN's
article to be at the front so even if he
were able to get some big headline he
had sympathetic out sympathetic
journalist take on his story cover it
accurately it doesn't mean that the
search teror the the the way the
algorithms work out will be evenly
applied to him do you hear what I'm
saying I think I like your metaphor
about get down Duck and Cover when the
fire when the incoming enemy fire is
happening and this is like when people
are writing crappy articles about you
like don't make noise cuz you're going
to look guilty but that's important why
you have allies to fire on the position
that's attacking your Foxhole to lighten
the fire so you cross that's right and
that's our job essentially right now is
what we're doing is we're we're exposing
this weird algorithm his people are evil
that's it I mean Twitter and Facebook
running backd doors allowing the
government to come in and and basically
get content removed it's
unconstitutional deep corrupt
deep corruption it's it's is it is pure
corruption and it is it is over evil
these people are doing it for personal
gain that's just it man we were talking
about free speech I had interviewed
Josie the redheaded libertarian today on
my YouTube channel we were talking about
free speech and how like the ability for
a private company just to shut off a
bunch of people's ability to communicate
or the way certain aspects of my
communication with you might not show up
like that's we wrote a constitution and
fought a revolution to avoid that from
happening we had the king pressing down
on our necks ctively and disallowing us
from speaking out in public no more
never again that was the point but this
also happens with companies that control
Banks right I mean PayPal can say I
don't like what you're talking about
online you can no longer use our service
which makes it actually difficult to do
a lot of business interfacing this is
true of MailChimp this is true of a ton
of different companies that decide we
don't want to be associated with you
because we have a vague termice that's
like the next level is when it's
transactions that is the next level like
that's the deeper level below free
speech that's the foundation if you
can't if you don't have the freedom
transa then you're like what what can
you do it's like the truckers in Canada
they just they just shut them down I
just think we're winning across the
board in every way I mean we got a super
chat a moment ago and they were like how
could how could the Democrats even put
someone else on the primary ballot
because it's too late in several States
Biden can't win the dude's completely
out of his mind he's losing support
among the the Hollywood Elites Michael
rapor says he's going to vote for Trump
or he's considering voting for Trump I
mean this is crazy Elon Musk filing the
lawsuit everybody's going on on offense
and I can tell you this too ladies and
gentlemen I can't say too much cuz in
ter in legal issues you know you got to
keep things pretty quiet until you make
your moves but there is so much more
happening behind the scenes let's just
I'll just put it this way many phone
calls many phone calls have been
happening and there's a lot of prominent
individuals who are Like This Is War
there was a post recently where someone
suggested that any prominent influencer
on Twitter should should file an amicus
brief or join the lawsuit Elon Musk is
filing because guess what everybody you
know that money you were making on
Twitter oh wow it's gone it's all gone
so when I was getting two to 3,000 bucks
every two weeks maybe about five grand a
month gone so Media Matters did not just
smear and defame Elon musk's platform
but stripping revenue from everybody
through fraudulent means yeah so there's
a lot and there's a lot more than that
so uh yeah Media Matters is the worst
we're still spending a lot with X how's
it been how how's the engagement been
well it's great this is with sound of
Freedom was the first time that and this
is within months after a very short time
after Elon acquired Twitter is that our
our main investors uh Giga fund that's
invested in SpaceX invested in a whole
bunch of Elon companies um they they
they called us and they were like hey
how can we improve the system so they're
they're working very hard to improve the
Twitter advertising system and it's
working like
Twitter has not com had a competitive
leg that even comes close to competing
with Facebook for targeted ads and
direct response ever and now they're
starting to compete like advertisers
need to be aware it's worth taking time
to invest in Twitter now part of the
reason why sound of Freedom was
successful was because Twitter figured
out how to make ads work and they're
getting better and they're getting
better and better and so I I think that
this Twitter just has to survive the dip
and then they'll climb back out of it
because they're actually innovating
they're actually making changes and
they're listening to the audience and
the customers and so uh for us we spend
where it works and I I I think that um
if we can do I mean we're known Harmon
Brothers known for doing poopery Squatty
Potty purple mattress Lumi deodorant
these billion dooll cpg companies and
mattress companies and and um and these
like this I can tell you Twitter is
starting to figure it out we're going to
be doing a big ad ad push in the
beginning of next year we we're we're
already doing uh big ads for infringed
our latest documentary by Lauren
Southern and johnis and uh when they
announced they were pulling out it was
Seth Dylan who started the Cascade
saying we're to commit 250k I said I'm
on board and uh it's just the easiest
marketing play in the world join in the
fun Everybody by announcing we're doing
an ad buy we get 10 times the Press from
our from the ad buy so like let me let
me just stress I want to buy ads on X we
did we were already buying ads we we we
we created a $50,000 budget for
infringed and launch that campaign and I
we we are having some issues so I need
someone from Twitter's help but uh we
can I can we can make some connections
yeah that'd be great because like I
don't know I I something weird is
happening in the backround but I digress
so uh when this this when when Seth
Dylan's like Hey we're going to do this
thing I was like well we're already
advertising on X we already want to want
to do more let me just announce that I
too will be doing this en joining their
efforts exactly right and then I get
articles written about me so standing up
for what I believe in results in 10
times the the Press we would have gotten
just off the ad campaign alone the Tweet
announcing the ad campaign got 7,000
retweets so it's just the marketing
rights itself let's you know you know
this idea I had a long time ago
marketing should do something good was
was you know it reminds me of that movie
um Hancock where Jason bait's character
is like everyone puts the hard on their
brand I'm like well that's kind of dumb
my idea was companies should compete
with how much they can accomplish
ideologically in in alignment with their
values so uh you know for instance
instead of spending $50 million doing
this Nationwide campaign where you hire
a celebrity to throw a football you
spend $50 million investing in Road
schools or you know veterans like
helping veterans or nonprofits and then
instead of doing this big commercial
where a celebrity throws a football you
just do a commercial where it's a guy
standing in front of like a a VA saying
instead of spending $50 million on
throwing a football we just gave it to
wounded veterans to help those and I'm
like that's the kind of marketing we
should be doing competing with each
other to do the most good so I'm like if
I can buy ads to promote Tim cast.com
and the projects we're doing and it has
the added benefit of winning the culture
War man I'll spend all my money let's
just let's roll you think Mr Beast he'll
actually take cameras in and show the
people crying with joy from tasting
fresh water for the first time in their
lives and things and you may argue it's
exploiting the people that are getting
the video taken of them but he's giving
away Wells and they attacked him for it
the media came after him well he's an
oppressive figure trying to help
people guarantee he's he's anything but
and you should watch his video where he
brings 100 Wells to people that are
starving of fresh water essentially
dying you know having distended stomachs
and these little kids these this fly is
driving me nuts are you guys watching
it's attacking everybody anyone that
starts to talk it's like hostile work en
go straight to the speaker holy
crap I just swatted and didn't squeeze I
had like some some sympathy for if we
just open the door and cross our fingers
that he leaves yeah I'll do that there
you go yeah the flyes attacking
everybody fun while it last and fly well
he's gone buzz off what were you saying
Ian before awesome thing oh about Mr
Beast uh he was just showing video of
these kids and I mean if you've ever
spent time with kids in like um in a
impoverished impoverished nation and you
see them kids that drink poop water
basically the same river water that they
drink out of they poop into it's sad cuz
their stomachs are fat and Bloated I saw
it in South America when I was in Peru
and it was there's so happy people cuz
they don't know they didn't know but
once they found out they wereing livid
and and it's just to be able to to help
people children especially thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at timcast.net